hello internet people
hello I am Falvo I am a brother a leek
and today neatnik busy today so he asked
me make boy lesson for you ok so we do
poi together ok
so Nick Nick pretty good you know what
for a pretty good teacher he tells you
how to do aunty speedy tell you how to
do many patterns we tell you how to
develop a freedom of movement but he
don't tell you how to find your passion
uh-huh see he not tell you so it
difficult thing a difficult thing so but
I grew up in old country
so we know passion we know how to find
the passion I learned poi in Ibiza and
any beef that we have passion so you do
with me you get poi you do with me I
teach you passion okay but you do hear
the rule you do you do then you okay you
judge but you don't do then you judge it
it's okay okay
so get poi and I show you the passion
[Music]
so the passion is not something you find
in your mind it's something you find in
your back you have to make some movement
with the spine with you have to breathe
you have to move your booty if you do
this then you find the passion now the
boy can be any movie want with the boy
in the bikini
no no important no matter but you have
to move the party to sit the weave maybe
and then as you move the party you feel
some energy as you move the body you
start to feel your passion you move on
you breathe more you feel more in comes
to you as the passion comes the
creativity it comes to you start to see
your cartoons nobody watching you you
try you move you feel your passion it's
not sexual okay maybe a little bit
sexual you move you try as you feel
you'd walk time to movements feel the
dance comes to you the passion the
passion rules you the dance moves your
back
you start to feel the life force energy
you start to feel you're sure but you
have to move your back here you have to
move your booty you have to move your
thigh
[Music]